this is gonna be more matches than I
have ever or will ever you you think so
yeah
this is like I guess you don't smoke if
the lifetime's worth of matches yeah
probably right
hello there lovely Internet I'm Gavin
I'm done with the slow mo guys down
we're doing a match bomb yep I've got
here in my hand
about three hours worth of work it's
about six thousand match heads we've
chopped up here and they're stuck in
this saucepan it took a really long time
the Mythbusters did this with I think a
million match heads yeah I'm not gonna
sit there to do a million six thousands
enough I think yeah I think they had a
few more employees to help out with the
match heads yeah I saved one match what
we're gonna do is chuck it in there and
watches it all goes up at the same time
hopefully they'll combust and a leap up
out of the air spinning burning and
making a quite a high flame don't try
this at home probably okay it's got me
very careful how do we get pouring
saucepan what do we get a funnel think
about this sorta quick Oh God going
everywhere oh my work going thirsty hey
lovely okay
lovely so you're the Phantom flex for K
doing a wide we got a tight on the
Phantom flex whoof
let's see how I should yeah I'm nervous
hey let me just black reference
all right it's just these are the
matches was cuz you put it on the top
like that there you go
watch that what's up
you know even though
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
Oh careful gave a government smells so
good they like ant they're learning
trying to escape something get me out of
this blender that's crazy the amount of
just flying out of it
Alex so long yeah oh it's like great
it's literally raining fire it's crazy
that the fire meant that the matches
were literally lifted out of the
container what makes them lift up like
that is it just melts they're so light
in the heat lifts them I guess so yeah
like a hot air balloon yeah pretty much
we may have given the other leaves a
little bit of a char are there well in
that chaos with some lovely slow motion
very punchy actually I think that's what
we do best we find the beauty in the
dangerous and the chaotic that was very
profound actually yeah quite impressed
made it up on the spot that was good if
you enjoyed that video feel free to
subscribe you're getting alert every
time we upload a video you can follow us
on Twitter I wouldn't drink that I
wouldn't even smell it let's be honest I
think it's poisonous yeah probably not
agree I don't put that down yeah pop it
down yeah you comes to buy a shirt by
slow-mo shirt by erisa t-shirt it's all
good yeah hopefully we'll see you in the
next video sweet
you
[Music]